well I can't talk about this movie
unless I show this clip there's really
no point in hiding it we all know what
happens to Bambi's mom in this movie and
it messed up so many kids for life but
is that the only reason to enjoy Bambi
the answer is obviously no not only is
the art in this movie just fantastic I
mean good god you just feel like you're
in nature throughout this entire film
but it's the first time Disney's ever
done a coming to age story and it
doesn't very well where Disney's always
been good at creating villains and
threatening obstacles to go up against
they knew to keep that to a minimum in
this movie the villain is man and you
never see him but just the mere threat
of him is enough to be intimidating
everybody talks about the mother's death
but some of these other scenes can get
pretty damn intense we better fly you
don't fly whatever you do don't fly he's
almost here
like most of the early Disney films and
mixes bright and colorful with darkened
mommy killing but let's be honest it's
not the death of the mother that gets us
it's the fact that there was such a
strong connection between her and the
Sun that's why it messes us up and I
also like the fact that the father is
almost never around and when he is
baby's almost afraid of him sir a
fascinating dysfunctional family that
may or may not need to be but again
that's sort of up for debate and that's
one of the reasons I do like this film
so much the answers are not clear-cut
hell even the questions aren't clear-cut
it's just the life of this deer and all
those typical children's cliches that
you see in other kids films oh hell you
see another adult films for that matter
are not here and thank God because you
know what this is enough sometimes just
showing someone or something live their
life is all you need life is interesting
life has problems life doesn't always
resolve itself in a clever and poetic
way life doesn't always have heroes life
doesn't always have villains so because
of that as you'd imagine there's less of
an emphasis on story and more on
character while Bambi is not the most
fascinating of characters he's supposed
to be sort of the every guy he's the
blank slate that's supposed to absorb
love fear sadness happiness and whatever
other emotions you can connect with I'd
be lying if I said I watched this one a
lot in fact it's probably one the Disney
films I watched the least though I do
own it but I definitely respect him more
than I do view it I guess there's only
so many cutesy wutesy scenes I can sit
through but they are done well and with
purpose the second half is at to where I
start to get more interested I mean you
know after that scene
I like seeing Bambi grow up I like
seeing what he's become and I like
seeing what he's going to make of
himself it's another one of those films
with the lack of really complex
characters is made up for and how much
complexity they put into the backgrounds
and the colors at the time the sceneries
give you the emotions I like a film I
can do that without cheating on the
character necessarily the emotions are
there in the character they're just
emphasized by the surroundings Bambi is
chock full event heavy atmosphere in a
heavy environment
it's easily one of Disney's finest
Oh